I love fear.
Fear is fuel.
I kind of joke, but not
really, that I put fear
in my bowl of cereal in
the morning, and I eat it.
I was not an athlete as a kid.
I say that I was actually
allergic to exercise.
So the fact that
working out is actually
my life's work is
astonishing, definitely to me,
and everyone around me.
I am a reformed lawyer
turned ultramarathoner.
I'm Head Instructor
and Vice President
of Fitness Programming
at Peloton,
and I am here to start fires.
We can absolutely
change our stories.
I am living proof.
If you're coming to this class
expecting me to teach you
the nuts and bolts
of fitness, that's
not going to happen today.
In my MasterClass, we're
going to be applying
the principles of
movement, and fitness
to business and storytelling.
We're going to talk about
ways to plot dreams using
things like journaling and
visualization techniques.
Even if you don't consider
yourself an athlete;
even if you also think that
you are allergic to exercise.
The principles of
endurance, power, strength,
they apply to every
industry, everyday.
Two weeks before I started
working at Peloton,
I was diagnosed as
a type 1 diabetic.
My pancreas stopped
producing insulin.
Completely unexpected;
and in that moment,
I had to decide, "do I
crumble, or do I pivot?
Am I a victim to this, or am
I still victorious, despite?"
Movement is therapy for me.
The process of training, and
having something to focus on,
and having something that
was for me, changed my life.
Now we are going to get
you from wherever you
are to where you want to be.
We're going to
get uncomfortable.
This class is for anyone who
has a glimmer of curiosity about
what's possible for themselves.
I'm Robin Arzón, and
this is my MasterClass.
This is baby's
first MasterClass!